a e aí galera que aceite meu canal tudo
com você risos olha só que beleza hein
casey demorei tanto a fazer um vídeo
novo que eu voltei atacava roupo tare
área foi muito louco eu passei eu gravei
meu show porque você já assistiu passei
três meses de férias meses depois o
caseiro agora só volta na ativa de novo
com vídeo com chow chow chow está
voltando e se ele voltar a rodar o
brasil é o mundo um show novo chama
heitor casei na verdade esse show falou
sobre isso você se torna adulto só vocês
e independentes ou você é escolher a
pessoa porque você vai viver o resto da
sua vida já tenho os dados aqui vou
falar pra vocês autor música bem legal
enquanto edgar data dia 7 de abril agora
sábado jaraguá do sul santa catarina e
18 de abril em biguaçu santa catarina
dia 14 de abril boa vista roraima jato
novo em nota no dia 15 de abril perdia
piauí 13 e nem mundial e 21 de abril
belo horizonte minas gerais 22 de abril
campinas são paulo 27 de abril macapá e
21 de abril o porto velho rondônia em 29
de abril o rio branco no acre faz tanto
gostou muito e só de você rio branco é
nóis 29 de abril rio branco acre na sesi
em muitas outras cidades você comprar os
ingressos em transe site ingresso.com.br
eu cheguei pra mim falou assim ah e
hasan
i
e aí como é a vida de casado de que vida
tem um mês que o causado devido foi
assim que passou em um mês foi acontecer
a ficar a pagar para jogar bolinha é não
sei se eu chamo into eu ia agora é
casada né
minhas pernas agora face da moeda é uns
amigos chega pra mim falou assim ah sou
bicho agosto colocando o dedo o bambolê
de otário fundador de um cabaz com a
namorada cultura minhas forças para
largar tudo para ele ver com você e tem
um filho de uma família muito simples
família a moça de final e quando você
vai casar aparece um monte de gente que
sabe tudo sobre o casamento não sei por
que uma pessoa fala assim eu isso já
pegou os papéis num momento nos
alicerces matrimoniais em assinar o
bicho não não fiz e não olha como não
fazia buscas online importante do
caminho garante ter feito isso há oito
meses atrás como seu entender se eu
soubesse a boca de casamento é a
primeira vez que o caso não é só a
gretchen não mas o papel do brigadeiro
já escolheu ele não visse um saber que
escolheu o papel dele não cassei
condições como não sabia o papel do
brigadeiro um casamento a coisa mais
botão do casamento cópia brigadeiro
[ __ ] lá saber porquê papel de
brigadeiro não como brigadeiro o papel
não botar botox e papel com duas coisas
matrimoniais pegasse na igreja já está
um pouco tarde o vista não sabia não te
fazer o papel em casa quando vê o papel
que é mais importante do casamento a
campeã de grand slam você escolheu o
negócio matrimoniais o papel brigadeiro
ou é o papel dele não tem conserto da
fama é importante eu acho que o mais
importante do casamento era cavar ela
chega lá fala assim jesus escreveu no
livro da vida o ente casou menina tá aí
jesus levantar que está aqui está a
ouvir na hora eu tava na hora mas não
muita coisa que meu deus do céu que
agora são duas famílias gaúchos e os
nordestinos agora casado tac ou
parcelado cravou agora no final do ano
em um lugar o reino unido chega no lugar
dos gaúchos gaúcho bate parabéns e agora
é um homem de família e também na minha
volta e eu cheguei o meu amigo não tem
razão eu tive lá cada guia é sobre quem
só por ramiro brinquei promover essa
família no interior dela no meu interior
gravado no interior dela música vai ser
essa raça
um chimarrão ano do tabaco é que eu vou
levar minha família lá agora no meu
interior é legal falar musicais é assim
a de suva gatinha de fritura pela coisa
e ainda caseiro alagoas caras para
marilyn do brasil na lagoa no dia 25 de
maio tem show em maceió lagosan em
maceió não esquece como foi o caso em
são miguel dos milagres de maceió depois
três horas indisponível ou até melhor a
inversão já arrumamos um lugar para
ficar tudo tranquilo não tem que se
preocupar com nada os velhos já remoto
após atento a gente ficou todo oficina
do amigo
a nova norma é e eu de actor jesse tanto
de gêmeos graças a deus que arranje um
parceiro a pousada ribeira dos milagres
lá em são miguel na qual marina que tem
como dar meus amigos sim de um jeito
sensacional valeu da pousada esse aqui é
o caso esteja em paz são miguel dos
milagres e quer ficar lá aqui está
tranqüila e aí a gente realiza o
casamento que o lançamento é ver com a
noiva para o casamento é um negócio a
noiva no you tube é um mero coadjuvante
do casal k olha agora tá na hora de ir
pra casa da noiva falei em um casa para
8 nem a casa do noivo em isso noivo quem
quer que for que é noivo cara de caso
com a aac casa não não tem amanhã e os
horários da noiva 8 horas da manhã no
olival à porta um banho de sais 96 café
extenso com frutas cereais legumes dia
massagem meio dia 3 em 37 segundo num
evento em que tem na nova lei pra mim
vai ter alguma coisa e você 36 tem
relato feito à noite você ninguém se
pode chegar de bicicleta e sunga pede
papo ou para fora chegar vamos ver lá
parabéns a ele pelo crédito pela noiva
emagrecer por casamento ainda que diz
não agora tem que emagrecer para entrar
no término de mais gente tira medida do
terno e esse tamanho que eu era nesse eu
tenho quinta não há dieta o casamento
porque é coisa importante agora não
perde há bocado mesmo que a coisa ande
boa noite o canal meio de ano ela vai
tentar emagrecer entra em pouco de
negócio e vão pôr os filhos vão fazer o
cross fit de bom fazer o cross fit que
eu vejo namorada gabriela problema no
leque é tolerado de anderson deu um
abraço e cosme furo uma barriga dura e
caiu na barriga um balde branco do acre
já construiu a casa em cima lei pronto
vou geração saúde é desse jeito que eu
quero eu quero brincar eu quero ser o
cara eu quero ser uma tela do iphone
quando cai no chão trincado no primeiro
dia eu cheguei próximo de ocara bola
pega esse pneu de trator leva por outro
lado eu falei meu filho e levantar por
de pneu de trator maluco era casada
havia um vingador não é que escolhi as
músicas do casamento que é a coisa que
não tem como mais escolheu hoje é músico
que as músicas de hoje é tudo [ __ ] é
tudo [ __ ] da toccato da uplay na
música rola na tocado um grupo tarefa é
a música você não sabe como ela é eterna
que ela começa assim uma melodia é a
gente brigou eu mandei embora os
primeiro dia de sanfona banana manga
banana votada o sai começa assim né nos
vai começa a dançar só não começa então
joga então jogue o velho que então jogo
poupou na piroga vem para no meu deus eu
estou dançando por isso que a coluna da
gente quebra quando a gente fica velho
para não dançar essas coisas não têm
como que uma [ __ ] de antigamente é
[ __ ] que você conseguir mexer é uma
gostosa lapada na rachada você pede que
eu te dou na parada na rachada e gostoso
lapada na rachada toma toma toma o que é
uma lapada na rachada não tem como saber
o que é assim do delegado vai ter
confusão do forró chicão rolou eo zé
bombom e foi o que aconteceu e chegou
ontem um formal e um cara que não gostou
que o japão vai lá isso é legal de
cuidado com a confusão a história não
tem nada hoje um perigo de deixar sua
playlist do spotify tocando seu
casamento nada começa o nénão
ana na maioria das amigas da minha e me
manter em mindanao
ei todo mundo quem foi que disse mato
mim divulgar seu lobby é que o prefeito
até que os escorregas pq tu na orelha
por meu pau a levantar um negócio assim
tão pesado que o epa minha vã dou graças
a deus que ela sou eu vou ter que soltar
uma música no som da ufam de ouvir por
velho tem condição vários cartões que
envolve 70 responsabilidade de ir para
casa depois de sair de casa de de criar
cachorro em casa de comprar sua própria
comida e fazer sua escolha de casar
envolve então eu criei um show novo
chama está casey vai estar nessas datas
o que eu falei lá se você gostou desse
vídeo clique gostei aqui não esquece
clicar em gostei muita gente esquece
está com outros vírus carregando e
muitos de vocês estão assistindo o vídeo
foi pela divulgação do instagram das
redes sociais não são escritas no canal
se inscreve no canal nunca perdeu um
vídeo onde eu quero que você comente
aqui em baixo pode comentar aqui embaixo
qual é a música perfeita pra tocar o seu
casamento um dia você for casar com a
música perfeita que vai colar o seu
casamento aqui embaixo do meu casamento
acho que não tinha uma trilha sonora
quando quatro horas da manhã todo mundo
dançando era gaúcha nordeste no dia
todinho a música no casamento é super a
catinga de chuva
gatinha de preto disse